[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
discussing one of the most important
dates
in the harry potter story and that is of
course the day
that lord voldemort traveled to godric's
hollow to murder the potters
more specifically i'm going to be
discussing the actions of albus
dumbledore and rubius hagrid
immediately after the potters were
murdered by voldemort
when the potters were murdered it was a
shock to everyone particularly
as seemingly every preventative measure
had been put in place to keep them safe
when sybil tralani announced the fabled
prophecy and that
the one with the power to vanquish the
dark lord approaches voldemort went into
panic mode
at this point in time he was at the
height of his power and
as a result of his lesions of followers
was seemingly untouchable
this meant that the imminent threat of a
prophecy in his defeat
was at the forefront of his mind and it
also meant that he would do whatever it
took to make sure the potters
the family whom he was certain the
prophecy pertained to were killed
the primary defense protecting the
potters was the fidelius charm
a powerful piece of magic involving a
secret keeper a witch or wizard
that conceals a secret inside of their
soul in this instance
the secret was the location of the
potters normally
this sort of magic would have worked
perfectly and protected the potters
however the poor choice was made to make
peter pettigrew secret keeper
and he inevitably gave them away to the
dark lord
and so on the night of october 31st
voldemort traveled to the potter cottage
with a knowledge of their whereabouts
when the dark lord finally entered the
godric's hollow home it wasn't long
before he made quick work of james
potter
from there he began making his way into
the room with lily and harry
voldemort's target was harry this was
because he was the chosen one
the boy with the power to vanquish him
voldemort went straight for harry
however when lily got in the way
voldemort put an end to her life
however what he didn't know was that
lily had cast a loving sacrifice
a means of ending her life to protect
harry's this meant that when voldemort
finally fired his killing curse at harry
it rebounded back at him effectively
ending his reign of power
for a little while but one thing
peculiar about that night is
that hagrid and dumbledore were
seemingly aware of the potter's death
nearly instantaneously neither hagrid
nor dumbledore was secret keeper so
just how did they learn of their deaths
so quickly no problems were there
dumbledore asked no sir house was almost
destroyed but i got him out all right
before the muggle started swarming
around
he fell asleep as we were flying over
bristol dumbledore and professor
mcgonagall bent forward over the bundle
of blankets
inside just visible was a baby boy fast
asleep
under a tuft of jet black hair over his
forehead they could see a curiously
shaped cut
like a bolt of lightning so if the house
was almost destroyed
which would certainly draw a lot of
attention how on earth could hagrid have
gotten there
before muggles started swarming around
if a house in my neighborhood blew up
i'm fairly certain that people would
arrive within minutes if not
seconds so how was hagrid there i'm
fairly sure that it would have been
dumbledore who instructed hagrid to go
and pick harry up
so more importantly how did dumbledore
know i won't lie
the very fact the dumbledore knew of
their deaths so quickly
is a bit suspect and it makes my mind
question the morality of his character
however i'm not going to elaborate on
that further because it turns out that
jk rowling has actually addressed this
issue in an interview
how did dumbledore find out about what
happened in godric's hollow
and what happened there's this whole 24
hours that people have been fantasizing
about
for years yeah i know i've got a bit of
a problem with this myself
because every time i think it's straight
in my head i go back and look at what
the fans are theorizing about
i think yeah maybe they've got a point
dumbledore
well there's an easy answer to how we
dumbledore now yeah
so okay obviously dumbledore could cast
a spell on a dwelling
that would immediately alert him if
something happened to it so he could
know instantaneously
that's not a problem at all and then he
could dispatch hagrid and so on
this is not an amazing answer but it's
an answer nonetheless
and it does sort of make sense why
wouldn't a powerful wizard like
dumbledore
be able to set up a form of tripwire
type magic
it's a level of magic that would
certainly not be beyond a powerful
sorcerer such as himself
though less exciting than the prospect
of dumbledore being evil
and allowing the potters to be killed it
turns out that this
is the answer and that's it for this
video did you guys know the answer to
this question
do you think rowling is covering up the
model's true nature
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
there is plenty to be learned even from
a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
you